[Music]
and now to a related story today at a
house weaponization Committee hearing
independent journalists Michael
shellenberger and Matt taibe worked
overtime in an effort to explain to
skeptical Democrats how coordinated
censorship between US government
officials and social media companies is
a flagrant constitutional violation now
the democrat's chief synic was New York
Dan Goldman who tried out a neat new
trick he tried to redefine the First
Amendment part of the operation was to
change the terms of service so you see
them constantly trying to change the
terms of service you see them it was 35%
of of the URLs that wereing to EIP were
labeled removed or soft blocked that's
all forms of censorship that censorship
is not just removal but 65% were not so
how can the government be so coercive
the First Amendment for the course
government the First Amendment say The
Government Can censor Gent they're not
censoring they're flagging in the social
media
compan 35% of a First Amendment or it's
not the first amendment it's the terms
of service as you said and they are
flagging it for the social media
companies to make their own decisions
that is not the first amendment that is
the terms of service we have just seen
Congressman you're an attorney you know
that that four federal judges have
already ruled that and I know that it's
on appeal in front of the Supreme Court
right
now uh this that debate was very concern
that got to heart of the issue wow
joining me now Ohio Congressman Jim
Jordan chair of the house committee on
weaponization and Matt taiii a witness
and dare I say constitutional law
professor for Mr Colman today all right
Matt you mentioned something interesting
in the hearing which was fascinating to
watch now the fact that Free Speech used
to be just something we prbly agreed
upon as an American
ideal but that's out the window can you
explain
that I I can explain it I mean ie grew
up um a traditional kind of liberal I I
donated to the ACLU my whole life uh and
I got most of my ideas about speech from
uh Democrats people like Frank church
and Paul wellstone and Russ fold and
there is no element of that left in the
Democratic party in fact today was kind
of an epiphany for me I I've kind of
given up trying to convince people in
this party to care about this issue they
just do not any anymore uh it's not a
value that they uh treasure at all well
Congressman to this point and I also
wanted to get your reaction to something
else that Dan Goldman uh said when the
hunter Biden laptop issue came up check
this out you have no idea you know hard
drive a conspir are you suggesting the
New York Post participating in a
conspiracy to construct the contents of
the Hun bid laptop no sir the problem is
that hard drives can be manipulated by
Rudy Giuliani or Russia the evidence
that that happened well there is actual
evidence of it but the point is it's not
there's no evidence for it so you're
engaging in a conspiracy I'm glad okay
the fact that this man is in Congress is
a shock now Russia manipulated the
contents of the hard drive of Hunter
Biden you have to give him credit
Congressman for actually covering every
base here that's yeah shocking very yeah
very true but we actually had Witnesses
come testify that said the FBI knew that
the laptop was real they just didn't
want to tell us everyone knows it's real
for goodness sake we've seen the
documents emails and stuff that have
come from it so that was ridiculous but
this is scary where the because we had a
one of our other Witnesses made a great
point today as well she said when you
get rid of the First Amendment and the
fourth amendment that those are
foundational to the to to Western
civilization you don't have Liberty if
you don't have that and they they were
trying to censor election information
they were trying to censor Co
information it was scary where they went
where they want to go where the left
wants to take this but three big things
today we released a report that said
YouTube was being pressured by the Biden
Administration to take down content just
like they pressured Twitter just like
they pressured Facebook the two guys who
were responsible for this second thing
Andy slavit and Rob flarity we subpoena
them these were the two guys at the
Biden Administration and then of course
the big takeaway is the one you played
first 35% of uh taken down post and
stuff 35% censorship is still censorship
and frankly the other 65% is the
chilling effect you have on all speech
when there government saying you might
want to take these posts down that's how
frightening this whole thing is I just
keep thinking if Trump had done XY or Z
and coordinated XY or Z they would be
like chaining themselves to the White
House fence tonight all right Matt you
had a fascinating exchange with one of
our favorite congresswoman Debbie wasman
Schultz today will roll this should
social media companies allow rape and
murder to be live streamed by terrorists
on their platforms in order to create
fear and inight violence I believe that
would violate their terms of service
would so your answer is no it should not
they should not be allowed to do that
live stream rape and murder no I think
that I think that would count is speech
that would be prohibited under their ter
ter good good you do have absolutist
policies um but I do not have Absolut I
do I do not have please don't interrupt
me if the homeland security official
echoed your opinion you would call it
censorship so Matt she's trying to
equate live streaming a murder and a
rape to political or
scientific speech about the issues of
the day I mean how again I keep saying
these are people who are actually
elected to important positions of power
in our federal government and they're
just stupid people I'm sorry they are
stupid stupid people and I don't say
this as a you know former law clerk I
say this as an American they are stupid
and it's terrifying how stupid they
are I mean it's it's m blowing the the
the Dan Goldman exchange was incredible
to me I I wondered you know he's an
attorney I I I wondered if he ever did
defense law if he went into court and
said your honor my client only is 35%
guilty um was that was that the tactic
uh he was essentially conceding the
crime but saying it was only a
percentage crime uh and de waserman
Schultz uh said accuse me of saying the
exact opposite of what I set on record
uh probably more than a dozen times and
but that's been their tactic as the
chairman knows throughout the these
hearings they're not interested in the
in in the subject matter they just say
answer yes or no to this ridiculous
question and and that's their entire
contribution to the to the debate and
again everyone watching tonight I want
everyone to understand that Matt Tai and
I probably don't agree on much you know
right we're you're a liberal I'm a
conservative but we both believe believe
in the cherished Tim honored tradition
of free exchange of ideas free speech in
the United States we agree that's what
makes us special as Americans so that's
that's what it's all about have a great
debate disagree go have a beer whatever
but they don't want that they do not
want that to happen that is terrifying
for conservatives liberals who are true
liberals now Congressman today the
Washington Post reported that the
federal government has stopped warning
some social networks about foreign
disinformation campaigns the shift in
Communications signals how ongoing
litigation and Republican probes in
Congress are unwinding efforts once
viewed as critical to protecting us
National Security interest Congressman
it seems like this is a win for you all
because all of this was bogus from the
outset right and they're now saying
they're the victim so they've been
they've been involved in censoring
American free speech American First
Amendment Liberties and they're not
claiming oh we're the victims cuz we're
in we're exposing that give me a break I
mean this and and understand Laura this
is it's under the First Amendment you
can say things that aren't accurate but
what they were taking down yeah and not
popular but what they were taking down
was true stuff and you called you
relative to co you called this I
remember I I was you were interviewing
me on in April of 2020 and you said you
watch they will be taking down they're
coming after our liberties they'll be
taking down and they they were doing it
and so what Matt Tab and Michael
schelberg and these others who first
exposed the Twitter files someday in the
future they're going to look back and
these guys what they've done for our
country when they look back in history
they're going to say this was a great
thing and this is great that they're not
maybe conservative Republicans that
they're from the from the left but they
the first they love the First Amendment
this is not about left or right they
should win the Pitzer prize for what
they did both of them they're real
journalists I agree not sucking up to
you Matt but you're real you're a real
you're an actual journalist and you're
also a pH phenomenal writer my old
friend Don Imus uh loved you as well all
right gentlemen great to see you tonight
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else